Welcome to now you see it
One of the most important characters in a movie often times is actually the setting where the movie takes place in the same way that
A character has a personality influences the plot or represents a certain idea
So too can a setting just as effectively
Contribute to the mood style or themes in a story while settings always indicate time or place
I want to look at the many instances when setting goes even deeper and either gives insight into a character
symbolizes a certain idea moves forward the plot or
establishes mood a setting is wherever a scene takes place and can be anywhere from space to a desert to virtual reality [a]
Lot of the time a setting is an extension of a character depending [on] where a character works lives or spends their free time
We learn more about them perhaps [the] best example of the use of setting to describe a character is the Xanadu in Citizen kane this
Castle where Charles [Kane] lives is ridiculously large
Elusive secluded and creepy the inside of his mansion has many rooms [some] of them almost completely empty
others filled to the brim with Knickknacks
and other trophies kane cares nothing about his home seems either Barren or
artificially stuffed with objects for king to live there we infer that he's extremely wealthy looking to separate himself from the world lonely Empty and
Unsuccessfully filling his emptiness with pointless trophies this setting contrasts nicely with the small cozy Cabin
He lived in as a child which was much more intimate at homee
About [schmidt] has a similar use of setting if a character is introduced in a completely barren room
What does that say [about] the character in?
lost in translation
Charlotte and Bob feel confused and out of place in tokyo and the setting reinforces how they feel out of touch with their
Significant others as they grow closer and understand how to cope with their fears and problems the portrayal of tokyo goes from Dark and confusing
close-Ups at the beginning to clear Bright wide shots at the end the settings showcased their growth as
Characters a setting can also be a strong symbol in the movie and represent some idea for example Vietnam war movies usually
Portray the war as ambiguous
senseless and full of confusion and these ideas are
represented in the Dense Dark and
Menacing jungle where it's oftentimes hard to tell friend from foe in Little Miss sunshine the beauty pageant represents a flawed?
American Dream Beauty Pageants are a strange phenomenon American society where little [girls] are paraded [onstage] and judged on their outer appearance
[the] film uses the setting of the beauty pageant to Critique how the American dream is composed of
superficial and unfulfilled goals [the] pageant is a
Representation of those who buy into this false dream the family member is rejecting the beauty pageant in defining their own happiness themselves Conveys
The message that one's worth is determined
[by] the self and not by a panel of judges [a] similar example would be office space where his office
Represents a world where people put financial security at a well-paying job over their own happiness [a] setting can really represent
anything in life of [Pi] Pi's journey across the Ocean is a
representation of his spiritual journey while the meaning of this setting is more strongly emphasized in the novel the film still makes the connection between
His spiritual journey across the Ocean and a person's spiritual Journey in life one important part of his journey is landing on the Moving Island
while he can survive on this island the island is toxic and he would live his life trapped on it without completing his journey and
Dying alone and unfulfilled the island is a symbol of the choice everyone has to avoid completing his or her spiritual Journey the movie
Criticizes staying on this island [the] setting of the island represents an obstacle in every person's spiritual journey if someone wants they can never figure
Out what they believe in and instead remain on the Island [and] die unfulfilled and forgotten [the] movie
Criticizes this religious choice and uses the setting to convey this criticism. [I] saw how my life would end if I stood on that Island
Alone Forgotten [I]
Had to get back to the word or die trying
One important thing to know when analyzing a setting is what ends up happening?
To it do characters leave it or do they stay the most powerful ending of a setting is when it gets blown [up]?
Or burned down because that represents a rejection of whatever that setting
Symbolizes settings can act like characters when they influence the plot settings have the power to leave people stranded on a desert Island
Kill them or Force two characters to come together
We're moving
Characters can never truly remove themselves from setting and setting continuously gets used to advance
The Story forward not every setting has a higher meaning
But just about each one sets a certain mood for a scene film noir sets the mood of mystery and Deception by placing characters in
Settings with loss of shadow lighting and contrast another very common setting trope is menacing lightning which
Consistently conveys fear or doom often in a comedic way
Filmmakers really have limitless options in how a setting conveys a mood if someone is on a setting high up that shows power if someone
Is set low in the dirt it signifies a lack of Power emperor Kuzco?
Whether a setting is big cramped clean dirty safe
Or dangerous it can contribute infinite layers to a story setting is an underrated character settings [provide]. Just as much meaning
Symbolism plot elements and mood as a real-life character
So when analyzing is seen don't forget that just because settings are in the background doesn't mean they're not worth noticing. Thanks for watching
Also, [I] saw the Martian last weekend and wrote a review on it click the link in the description to [check] it out